but it's interesting the influence is
don rickles was a big influence rodney
was a big
influence what tell me about rod here i
want to hear continue but i got to hear
about rodney he's my friend
that's a picture of ronnie behind me
with red fox right there
oh two of the best they're having a
convo
um it's really um
weird because i mean and that's on my
instagram right now i posted it
and it's it's my set from the young
comedian special on hbo when i was 26 in
and rodney really loved me and i only
had
he i met him in la jolla at the comedy
store and he came in
and he was at la costa to clean up
because he had
uh you know been he's a partier you know
he loved pot i'm gonna smoke it every
day of my life man i don't care who
knows it
and and he uh he comes to the club with
two ladies i need
a lady on each arm and he goes oh man
i saw you on merv griffin man you got a
good head you're jewish you're
you're i had the curse okay you're
jewish all right how are you i
i have to curse you well i'll i'll do it
no curse what
are you doing okay yeah he went you're
jewish you're up you're never
gonna be happy
you know your mind can't stop working
you don't sleep
and my joke was a new friend you know um
and then he hung out with me all weekend
for three days rodney was everywhere and
he just we he saw himself and me
and always liked to help young comedians
but on this young comedian special i had
three minutes and 45 seconds but i'd
done a 15 minute set
and i introduced him to sam kennison and
i also got sam his first spot at the
comedy store
and so i had a closeness with sam in the
beginning of
after he was done being a faith healer
and wanted to be a comedian
right obviously we see what happened
with him um
and tragically his ending and rodney
i said why did i only have three out
three minutes and 45 seconds because i
was
you know i had a really great set he
went can't help it man i
sam sam crushed man i went well i i did
pretty good
and he went sam oh man sam i was like
okay
he always rejected by somebody so he was
oh god he was he was so funny so he
comes in he goes man
i don't know how i'm doing this this is
the comedy store in la jolla he goes no
booze no coke no pot no pills i don't
know how i'm doing it
wow that's a comedic sentence without
even effort
was he a lonely guy did you feel like
you ever really hey bob come hang out
with me
well i would hang out with him but he
also married joan
and so i would see
her and um and you know
he has two wonderful kids i don't see
brian or talk to brian
occasionally i talked to melanie i owe
her call melanie roy because rodney's
name was
jack roy right and before that it was
jacob cohen
and um so he went through a lot of
incarnations to try to survive
well he had a lot of problems with his
father right i read the book and he uh
we always wanted to get approval which i
could understand i always wanted
my father to be proud i always wanted
him you know he wanted love and when i
read that it made me cry because i
i thought i just want to make my dad
happy i just want to make him you know
like me and
and when i saw that other someone else
went through that it just
you know you get that feeling like oh
that's kind of like me i get it i get it